camus said
i see many people die because they judge
that life is not worth living
i see others paradoxically getting
killed for the ideas or illusions that
give them a reason for living
what is called the reason for living is
also an excellent reason for dying
i therefore conclude that the meaning of
life is the most urgent of questions
so i have to ask
what joshua bach is the meaning of life
it is an urgent question according to
kamu
i don't think that there's a single
answer to this
nothing makes sense unless a mind makes
it so so
you basically have to project a purpose
and
if you zoom out far enough there's the
heat test of the universe and everything
is meaningless everything is just a blip
in between and the question is do you
find meaning in this blep in between do
you find meaning in
observing squirrels
do you find meaning in raising children
and projecting a multi-generational
organism into the future do you find
meaning in projecting an aesthetic of
the world that you like to the future
and trying to serve that aesthetic and
if you do then life that has that
meaning and if you don't then it doesn't
i kind of enjoy the idea that you just
create the most
vibrant the most weird the most unique
kind of blip you can given your
environment given your set of skills
just be the the most weird
set of uh
like local pocket of complexity you can
be
so that like when people study the
universe they'll pause and be like uh
that's weird
it like looks like a useful strategy but
of course it's still motivated reasoning
[Laughter]
you're obviously acting on your
incentives here it's still a story we
tell ourselves within a dream that's har
that's hardly in touch with the reality
it's definitely a good strategy if
you're a podcaster
uh
and a human which i'm still trying to
figure out if i am yeah there's a mutual
relationship somehow somehow josh
you're one of the most incredible people
i know
um i really love talking to you i love
talking to you again and um
it's really an honor that you spend your
valuable time with me i hope we get to
talk many times throughout our
uh
through our short and meaningless lives
well meaningful or meaningful
thank you alex i enjoyed this
conversation very much
you